[Musica]
oggi ragazzi vi faccio vedere una cosa
che sta spopolando un sacco in america
che il flip fim io sono tra i pochissimi
ad avercelo in europa non mi sto
cantando ve lo giuro è un gioco che tu
lo lanci e lo riprendi in modi figli
cioè ci sono proprio dei trick che puoi
fare
alcuni sono anche qua dietro ho saputo
che una persona anzi un freestyler
professi un pelato mi ha sfidato ora
questi giochi questo caso del fim io
accetto la sfida perché non posso
permettermi di essere battuto da un
pelato prima sfida di oggi riuscire ad
aprire per maggiori informazioni ragazzi
vi lascio comunque il link in
descrizione con le varie informazioni
sul philippines e ci vediamo ai trick e
che vivi cavalca a a noi due
caro mio
[Musica]
ma vuoi veramente pensate che io non
riesco a fare meglio di una persona
senza i capelli bene possiamo cominciare
io ho difficoltà anche solo nel prendere
una chance io una volta ho fatto un
intero ho cominciato la cucina con un
coltello
però ciò non toglie che io possa essere
in grado di riuscire a fare
cominciamo bicchiere al centro rocca a
sinistra
tanta speranza
[Musica]
come ha fatto uscire deve arrivare fino
all'orlo eh no non è vero
[Musica]
vabbè ragazza non sa una foca io gioco
solo di palloni da calcio per cortesia
[Musica]
se dovete capire che plachi mini perché
dovete capire che maradona maradona non
guarderà questo video
[Musica]
credo di aver trovato la soluzione palla
nelle pitture ad esso possa fare dei
trick che giochino male qualche bravo
[Musica]
neanche così
signori state per assistere all'opera
più si verifica in catafratta della
vostra vita avanti
[Musica]
et voilà madame e monsieur le
e tu completezza e voilà è comunque uno
per a sibari tica catafratta comunque
sono già tv che ci stanno bene in tutte
le cose
questo è un film nel caso non si fosse
capito questa è la mia mano mi dovevo
pulire da qualche parte però è arte
ho sentito fanno tutti i pittori come
facciamo anche noi
[Musica]
io come mai mi sono tenuto carniere ben
prima che mai
basta ho capito
[Musica]
signori da quando vivo da solo
mia mamma mi ha lasciato un sacco di
vestiti da stirare lavare insomma è
stato difficile i primi tempi perché non
sapevo come farlo però adesso posso fare
talmente bene che oggi come sfida userò
il flip fim con una mano mentre con
l'altra stiro pronti e juan
[Musica]
mia mamma diceva sempre per stirare bene
si avrà concentrazione ma io non ho
bisogno di questo
io sono capace affari trip è una persona
che è capace a fare il trick una persona
che è capace a fare i trick non ha
bisogno di concentrazione le riesce
naturale
ok
[Musica]
però noi siamo in un altro un altro un
altro
[Musica]
cavalca
[Applauso]
[Musica]
va bè ragazzi e stancante però credo di
essere riuscito a prenderci la mano a
stavo stirando effettivamente dov'è
credo che questa era di mia mamma in
teoria beh secondo me è più bello ha
così rega non lo so c'è credo quindi
ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto spero che i trick siano stati
di vostro gradimento
la cosa importante che volevo farvi
capire è che nessuna maglietta è stata
maltrattata durante questo video la cosa
che ho imparato da questi trick e che
voglio farli per tutto il giorno fino
alla fine della mia vita
quindi ragazzi spero che video vi sia
piaciuto come vi ho detto prima vi
lascio indescrizioni link nel caso
volesse informazioni più e se vi è
piaciuto se tracciato un momento mi
piace anche vari social cominio della
descrizione settembre si ministro
facendo la chiusa di accendi la luce che
magari a bay un tipo anche al buio
illuminato
ok scendiamo vabbè adesso starà anche al
buio e volendo chissenefrega
[Musica]